En septiembre de 2017, Puerto Rico sufrió
el desastre natural más importante en sus
últimos 100 años.
El impacto del huracán
Maria, un enorme ciclón de categoría 4 de
un máximo de 5, con rafagas de viento superiores
a los 250km/h y lluvias torrenciales, causó
estragos en la isla. La destrucción fue enorme.
Miles de casas fueron arrasadas y toda la
red eléctrica puertorriqueña quedó prácticamente
destruida. La isla se quedó, literalmente
a oscuras.
Como os podéis imaginar los daños económicos
fueron gigantescos, hoy los costes de la reconstrucción
se estiman en cerca de 100.000 millones de
dólares.
Y no solo eso. Siete meses después, miles
de empresas continúan cerradas y los apagones
siguen siendo frecuentes.
Sin embargo, amigos, esperad un momento, porque
hablar del Huracán María no es contar toda la historia.
Lo cierto es que los problemas de la isla
empezaron mucho, pero que mucho antes.
Puerto Rico lleva más de 10 años sufriendo
una dura crisis económica y todo un éxodo
de población, un éxodo tan grande que amenaza
la propia supervivencia de la isla.
(Declarada en quiebra, en bancarrota, en mayo
de 2017, la situación es tan crítica que
el gobierno de la isla está estudiando trasladar
a miles de presos a cárceles privadas de
los Estados Unidos.
¿El motivo? El gobierno de la isla tiene
problemas incluso para financiar su sistema
penitenciario, y “alquilar” plazas en
lugares como Texas o Florida es más económico.)
[Un momento. ¿Prisioneros a Estados Unidos?
Sí, tal cual como lo escucháis. No olvidéis
que, aunque ni siquiera muchos estadounidenses
lo sepan, Puerto Rico forma parte de los Estados
Unidos. No es un estado, sino un “estado
libre asociado” con derechos políticos
muy limitados.]
En este vídeo te contamos que está ocurriendo
en esta isla situada en pleno caribe.
Atentos.
Formando parte de los Estados Unidos, teniendo
un clima tropical, una rica historia y hermosas
playas de arena blanca en las que, por cierto,
el mismísimo capitán Jack Sparrow vivió
algunas de sus más célebres hazañas, bien
podríamos pensar que Puerto Rico lo tiene
todo para ser uno de los lugares más prósperos
del mundo, ¿verdad?
Pues… esperad un momento, amigos, porque
la realidad es muy diferente.
Precisamente, en uno de nuestros primeros
vídeos, en uno de los primeros vídeos de
Visualpolitik, os contamos porque a Puerto
Rico su relación con Estados Unidos le está
causando últimamente algunos problemas. Al
final del vídeo y también en la descripción
os dejo el enlace.
[Por cierto, que tiempos aquellos.Cuando publicamos
nuestro primer vídeo sobre Puerto Rico apenas
éramos 1.823 personas. Hoy la comunidad de
Visualpolitik tiene casi 600.000 suscriptores
en castellano y 400.000 en inglés. ¡Un millón!
¡Qué pasada! De verdad, una vez más, ¡gracias
por estar ahí!]
Pero… continuemos.
Amigos, os hago una pregunta… ¿donde pensais
que viven más puertorriqueños? Parece una
pregunta tonta, ¿verdad? Pues, un momento…
ya os adelanto que la respuesta no es en Puerto Rico.
LA HUIDA
A primera vista Puerto Rico puede parecernos
un paraíso para vivir: buen tiempo, hermosas
playas, música… Sin embargo… la
isla tiene un problema enorme: cada año miles
y miles de puertorriqueños abandonan este lugar.
Vereis, desde 1917, los puertorriqueños son
ciudadanos de los Estados Unidos, son estadounidenses…
así que pueden moverse por el país libremente.
(Pues bien, según los datos del Pew Research
Center, durante la última década más de
500.000 puertorriqueños han abandonado Puerto
Rico para mudarse al continente, a lugares
como Texas, Florida, Nueva York o Pennsylvania.)
¡500.000 personas! Es una cifra enorme para
una isla de poco más de 3 millones de habitantes.
Visto de otra forma, tan solo en los últimos
10 años 1 de cada 7 habitantes se ha marchado
de Puerto Rico.
¿Os acordáis de la pregunta que os he hecho
hace un momento?¿Donde pensabais que vivían
más puertorriqueños? Pues la respuesta es
que desde el año 2006 hay más puertorriqueños
viviendo en los Estados Unidos continentales
que en la propia isla.
(“Lo que estamos observando es un importante
proceso de despoblación que no es muy común
en la historia moderna”. Lyman Stone, economista
e investigador sobre procesos migratorios.)
Y, ojo, porque la cosa puede ponerse mucho,
pero que mucho peor.
El propio gobierno de Puerto Rico espera que tan
solo, durante 2018, otros 200.000, 200.000
puertorriqueños se marchen.
Cuidado, estamos hablando de que Puerto Rico
va a perder cerca del 6% de su población
¡En un solo año!
Amigos… si este proceso, este éxodo estaba
ya siendo vertiginoso, las consecuencias del
huracán María lo han acelerado.
Diferentes estimaciones, tanto del gobierno
como de consultoras privadas, esperan que
durante los próximos 5 años, otro medio
millón de puertorriqueños hagan las maletas
y se marchen al continente,
(“Estoy muy apegado a mi isla, y mi preferencia
sería quedarme aquí, pero tengo que pensar
qué es lo mejor para mi hijo” Víctor Domínguez,
banquero hipotecario de 39 años en declaraciones
al Washington Post)
Cómo os podéis imaginar, semejante huida
de gente tiene consecuencias muy serias para
la isla, entre otras cosas porque los que
más se marchan son precisamente los jóvenes.
De hecho, se calcula que la mitad de todos
los emigrantes, de todas las personas que
abandonan la isla tienen menos de 24 años.
¿El resultado?
(Durante la próxima década la población
de Puerto Rico, se reducirá hasta los 2,5
millones de personas. Es decir, en la próxima
década Puerto Rico perderá 800.000 habitantes,
el 25% de su población- Atentos a esta previsión
de Lyman Stone.)
Y, ojo, porque de producirse otro desastre
natural, otro huracán por ejemplo, o si la
isla no consigue recuperarse de la dura crisis
que atraviesa… la realidad podría ser aún
peor…
¿Os imagináis lo que esto va a suponer para
la economía de la isla?¿Quien va a pagar
su enorme deuda? ¿Quien va a pagar las pensiones?
Pero... amigos… llegados a este punto…
creo que nos tenemos que hacer una pregunta,
¿Por qué se marchan tantos puertorriqueños?
Las estadísticas son propias de un país
en guerra… pero… en Puerto Rico no hay
ninguna guerra. Entonces, ¿qué está pasando?
Atentos.
(UNA CRISIS MUY LARGA)
¿Por qué se marchan tantas personas de Puerto
Rico? Amigos… si echamos un vistazo a los
datos… la explicación parece muy clara.
Casi la mitad de los puertorriqueños que
viven en la isla es considerado pobre - para
los cánones de Estados Unidos, claro.
El ingreso familiar medio es de apenas 20.000
dólares, que algo menos de la mitad del ingreso
medio de Misisipi, el estado más pobre de
la parte continental de Estados Unidos.
Pero no solo eso, además el gobierno de la
isla está en bancarrota y tiene una deuda
pública enorme: 70.000 millones de dólares
y otros 50.000 millones en compromisos de
pago, por ejemplo, en pensiones.
¡Recordad que estamos hablando de una isla
de poco más de 3 millones de habitantes!
Una locura.
Para que os hagáis una idea de lo que esto supone,
una familia media tendría que destinar íntegramente 6 años de su salario
para pagar la deuda pública…
Ahora ya podéis entender porque Puerto Rico
es conocida como la Grecia del Caribe.
Ahora bien, ¿Pensáis que hemos visto lo
peor? Pues… amigos, estáis equivocados.
(Lo peor de todo es que en Puerto Rico apenas
hay trabajo...de hecho la isla tiene la tasa
de actividad más baja de los estados unidos.
Tan solo 4 de cada 10 adultos trabajan o están
buscando trabajo.
Y ojo, si descontamos a las personas que no
tienen empleo y a los trabajadores públicos
- cuyos salarios salen de los impuestos de
las personas que trabajan en el sector privado
- el resultado es para ponernos en alerta:
menos del 25% de los habitantes de la isla
trabajan en el sector privado.)
[Por cierto, como curiosidad. Uno de los grandes
problemas de Puerto Rico es precisamente este:
los empleados públicos, los funcionarios.
Fijaos, casi 1 de cada 4 empleos de la isla
corresponde al gobierno y eso no es lo peor…
¿Sabíais que muchos de estos empleados públicos
tenían el derecho a jubilarse con 50 años,
15 años antes que en el resto de los Estados Unidos.]
Y, amigos, si os gustan las películas de
miedo, además podéis tener en cuenta…
que como los jóvenes se marchan… la población
de la isla está envejeciendo muy pero que
muy rápido.
En otras palabras… si no cambian las cosas…
la situación de Puerto Rico se va a poner
muy pero que muy difícil..
Pero vale, llegados a este punto, estoy seguro
que os estais haciendo una pregunta, ¿Cómo
diantres puede la isla salir de este berenjenal?¿Hay
realmente escapatoria?
Veámoslo.
( ¿CÓMO SALIR DE ESTA?)
Se suele decir que aquellos que no son capaces
de aprender de la historia están condenados
a repetirla. Puede que algo de esto ocurra
en Puerto Rico.
Cuando hablamos de cómo ven los políticos
locales el futuro… nos encontramos con algo
así como una de cal y otra de arena, con
cosas buenas y cosas no tan buenas.
Puerto Rico ha quebrado… y de seguir así
el gobierno puede llevar a la isla al abismo.
Por un lado es necesario recortar el gasto
público, frenar la sangría que ha provocado
semejante deuda pública.
(Y en principio, el nuevo gobernador , Ricardo
Rosselló, está por la labor, de hecho se
ha comprometido a reducir mucho el tamaño
del gobierno… el problema es que no está
del todo claro cómo lo quiere hacer, es decir,
no está claro que haya voluntad política
para corregir los grandes males de la isla.)
Por otro lado, Puerto Rico tiene que dar un
giro de 180 grados a su política económica
y poner en marcha planes serios para atraer
inversiones. Ojo, Puerto Rico necesita medidas
decisivas, reformas de verdad, no cambios
no cosméticos.
Bueno, alguna cosa se ha hecho en los últimos
años… por ejemplo, aprovechándose de lagunas
legales, se está tratando de convertir a
Puerto Rico es una especie de centro financiero
que garantice el anonimato a los inversores
internacionales.
Es un buen camino, pero hace falta muchísimo
más… pero de todo, como se nos está terminando
el tiempo, hablaremos en otro vídeo.
Ahora bien, antes de despedirnos, nos ha faltado
una pregunta muy importante que no podemos
dejar sin responder , ¿Cómo diantres ha
llegado Puerto Rico ha esta situación?
(Pues bien, un motivo ha sido que los gobiernos
locales han gastado enormes cantidades de
dinero en contratar, como hemos visto a muchísimos
trabajadores públicos, y también en carísimos
proyectos, en obras faraónicas que no han
aportado nada a la isla más que deudas)
[Menuda gestión]
El otro motivo tiene mucho que ver con la
influencia de Estados Unidos, pero eso ya
os lo contamos en este otro vídeo.
Así que ahora, turno para ti. Y en esta ocasión
te voy ha pedir que te mojes:
¿Crees que Puerto Rico debe seguir perteneciendo
a Estados Unidos o debería buscar convertirse
en un país independendiente?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta. Cómo siempre si
te ha resultado interesante el vídeo dale
a like y no olvides suscribirte al canal.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.